hi everyone in this video I would talk
about long-term potentiation long-term
potentiation exactly what does exactly
long-term potentiation means long term
means long lasting potentiation means
posted response here is our brain which
is formed of billions of neurons
connected to each other by synapses and
people have found out that underlying
learning and memory related tasks the
strength between the synapses the
conduction efficiency in this synapses
could change and the change of synaptic
strength or synaptic efficacy could be
long lasting as long as hours two days
and this kind of change in synaptic
strength which lasts long is known as
long term potentiation and let's just
look at the timeline long term
potentiation the phenomena was first
discovered at 1965 by please unknown and
what they have done is they have taken
take they have they have used a slice
brain slice based in artificial cerebral
spinal fluid and they are able to record
they can stimulate the presynaptic
terminals and they are able to record
from the posts in apps using recording
electrode now when they give a
presynaptic current pulse from the post
synapse they are able to record a
voltage change which is known as excited
to repost synaptic potentials or epsp
now they used a protocol which is known
as high frequency stimulation protocol
which is basically stimulating the
neuron with high frequency for quite a
lot of time after high frequency
protocol they give the same amount of
current injection that they have given
earlier but the same amount of current
injection has given rise to boosted
response means increase in postsynaptic
potential amplitude and this is the
measure of potentiated response other
way of understanding this kind of
readout is calculating the slope of post
potential now if you plot the slope over
time after high-frequency stimulation
they have found that the slope is always
increased that means synaptic strength
has altered synaptic strength is
increased because same amount of current
injection could now give rise to boosted
response our more voltage deflections
that means something is there in the
high frequency stimulus which can cause
this change and this is the experiment
that they have done they have taken
rabbit train and the rabbit brain that
they they did a coronal section they
paid the section in artificial cerebral
stuff spinal fluids of the section can
stay alive the neurons can stay alive
and it sufficeth they ensure that this
is a physiological situation and they
have stimulated the preferring path and
they have recorded from dentate gyrus
running cells and the performance part
comes from internal cortex to the
hippocampus and they are recording from
the granule cells when they are
stimulating the perforin but each time
they give a high frequency stimulus they
have seen there is a increasing
postsynaptic potential am preaching
postsynaptic potential slope the epsp
slope and they can see the posted
response lasts for several hours and
thereby they turned this kind of
protocol as long-term potentiation a
long-term potentiation created a massive
impact on neuroscience community a huge
excitement because long-term
potentiation has very good properties
like input specificity and cooperativity
let me explain what is input specificity
long term potentiation only happens in
two special in synapse specific manner
only the synapse which is stimulated
gets potentiated and that synapse has
alteration in synaptic strength or
efficacy they say here this synapse is
stimulated and the alteration in a
synaptic strength is specific to this
you know neuron and the blue neuron
synapse and cooperativity means that
potentiation of once in a
could lead do could influence the
potentiation of analysis in amps there
is certain degree of crosstalk that
means the potentiation of yoga synapse
would increase the likelihood that this
green neuron have its synapse would get
potentiated so this kind of good
computational properties led to the
understanding that this kind of
mechanism could be used by the brain to
encode memories and there is a huge
excitement at that time later people
found out that not only by artificial
stimulation people also can do
conditioning experiments learning tasks
and that can give rise to similar kind
of changes like in like the LTP protocol
suggesting the mechanisms which is
underlined which is underlying the LTP
protocol could be used by the brain to
encode memories so what is so special
about that high frequency stimulation
what does it do so let's say here is a
model neuron where you can stimulate the
presynaptic terminal in the presynaptic
terminal the action put potential flows
down and that would that would cause
presynaptic neurotransmitter release
assuming this is a butyl metal chick
synapse the neurotransmitter would be
glutamate and the postsynaptic wrist
move on there are there are glutamate
receptors like AMPA receptors and NMDA
receptors but they found out that NMDA
receptor has profound role on this
launch of potentiation now NMDA receptor
can understand the activity status of
pre snaps and the post synapse and it
can understand the coincidence between
the activity of the two neurons let's
see how it happens
now in MB receptor doesn't open when you
demand pint but AMPA receptor can open
when to the Med Pine and thereby
allowing sodium to get in because NMDA
receptor has a magnesium block in the in
the in the intermembrane sign inner
membrane side one sodium giving in
inside the postsynaptic membrane it
would depolarize the postsynaptic
membrane make it more positive and allow
the magnesium to repel out now the NMDA
receptor
can allow calcium influx and thereby
you're able to record a postsynaptic
potential so what exactly happens at an
immediate receptor level so an MD
receptor can understand the presynaptic
activity status and that is conveyed by
the glutamate because the in response
when the prison ops is active it would
release neurotransmitter
so the presynaptic activity status is
conveyed by the glutamate secondly the
post synaptic activity status is
conveyed by removal of the magnesium
block magnesium block would be only
revealed when the post synapse is
sufficiently depolarized thereby at a
molecular level presynaptic activity
status in the post synaptic activity
status could be coupled and thereby huge
calcium influx could happen people have
found that if you remove NMDA receptor
long-term potentiation doesn't happen so
what is exactly happening downstream to
NMDA receptor in brief NMDA receptor
allow calcium to get in and calcium
level rises from few hundred nano molars
to micro molars a tenfold increase in
calcium level and the brief increase in
calcium level has profound meaning the
spaceship temporal dynamics of calcium
has hidden messages inside it which
could be decoded by specific molecules
like kam k2 which is a calcium and
Cambodian based protein kinase now one
of the one of many things that calcium
dependent protein kinase cam k2 can do
is phosphorylating amp of mediating
vesicles the the AMPA receptors are
always ready to be delivered to the
surface but they are held by some
inhibitory molecules which don't allow
them to display in a normal case but
after calcium increase by long-term
potentiation cam k2 can phosphorylate
those vesicles and can can allow their
delivery to the postsynaptic membrane
now you can understand that AMPA
mediated current could increase and
which would in turn increase the
probability that nmd
scepter could open now an if enemy
receptor could be easily open once there
are way more ampere receptor display
combat membrane surface so at a
functional level at a functional level
this strength of the synapses has
changed people also found not only in
functional level also there are
structural changes in the postsynaptic
postsynaptic size the size of the
synapses also grow suggesting functional
and structural changes are associated
with long term potentiation so if you
liked my video please give it a thumbs
up don't forget to share my video and
please subscribe thank you